you know i've done this to you before
it's like previously in mathematics
extension one
we had perhaps for some of you a world
of pain as we were trying to understand
how to in this particular diagram i
wonder if the
gears are turning for you resolve forces
when you've got things going off at
weird angles
and we call this particular kind of
problem like it's common enough that it
gets a name
we call this a weight on an inclined
plane
because it's exactly what it sounds like
at least it does what it says on the tin
now in order to solve what's going on
here right
you might recall and i'm going to do a
quick and dirty diagram over here
you might recall that there was more
than one way
to solve such a problem now i'm
conscious of the fact that
not everyone gets shown every single
piece of this but um hopefully we'll
ring some bells for several of you
and for others it will yield some cool
insight here right so
you can see there are three forces being
or acting upon
our particular way on our inclined plane
right i haven't
um i haven't named all of them right you
can see you've got the
normal force which is there because why
why is the normal force there
hmm i could push on this right this
equal and opposing force right
strictly speaking i guess it comes from
the electromagnetic force right because
you've got electrons right
electrons in the plane that they want to
do anything
except for be at the same place as the
electrons
in the weight so they push right this is
why you've never touched something
in any moment in your life because what
you've experienced
is not touching but actually the
electrons
in the two hands the two parts of your
hand saying
i don't want to be there and so they
push against each other right
yeah okay so you've got the surface
the incline plane pushing against the
weight
in a direction perpendicular to the
surface
that's why we call it the normal right
uh what's that
teeth it actually stands for not just
tension but what's it actually coming
from
it represents something in this
situation come on it's a common
situation i think i heard it
yeah it's like a rope right there's
something which is
has tension in it that's pulling upwards
right otherwise the weight just
goes and slides down on the plane yes
and then our final force we're
interested in is
it's gravity right oh where's my green
uh the weight force thank you so you
know if we were
um if we were in space there's no weight
because um gravity's not acting on that
thing so
we've got our i'm gonna call that mg
as appropriate right so we've got these
and in order to get these to play along
with each other
you have to remember what's called
resolve forces
right now the traditional way is to say
well
the uh gravity force the weight force
rather
it's vertical okay so we can just leave
that that's nice and neat
and then we can say well the other two
forces in this we can
resolve number one in terms of their up
and down bit
right here's the tension and here is
this going horizontally and also i can
do this for the
normal first right so i've got this
going off this way and this is not quite
as far up do you remember this is this
ringing bells right
now you had to because i'm going to have
a whole bunch of right angle triangles
in here
you had to do there for a bunch of sine
and cos and then you get ratios you'd
make things equal to each other
if presumably this weight was not moving
down the plane
and then everything was fine right uh
fine
if you got the right answer now i said
right at the start this is not the only
way
to do it this is not the only way to
deal with all of the forces here
this is along the x y plane right
horizontal
vertical but i could look at the same
situation
and i could say wait hold on a second i
forgot that i can't do this on
on the board i don't need to look at it
like square on right
you could actually literally just take
your head and rotate it
anti-clockwise and look at this at an
angle
um so that you don't have to keep on
doing this the whole time i'm going to
try and do it for you
if i rotate it it's going to look
something like
this i guess right that can look right
i'm going to have this here which way is
the i'm now looking as if
i'm in line with the incline plane right
which way is the tension force going to
go in this scheme
it's going to go to the right
importantly for me not that it's left or
right but that it's
exactly horizontal right just like this
weight force used to be exactly vertical
this is exactly
horizontal which way is the i should
label that which way is the normal force
going to go
it's going to go straight up it is nice
and neat and
vertical in this scheme along the
inclined
plane the one problem is uh i still have
to deal with the weight force right
where would the weight force be going in
this game how would you describe it
to the diagonal perpendicular to the
diagonal you're so helpful yes okay well
i mean this is this used to be my
horizon
it was horizontal right so i guess kind
of if you want to think about being
perpendicular here being orthogonal
it's gonna be hitting off in this
direction do you agree something like
that okay
so you're never gonna get away from the
fact you have to resolve some forces one
way or another but at least in this
situation i only have to resolve
one the weight force whereas here i've
got two right so if you can do the
mental gymnastics to
think about how this works it's
advantageous to you does this make sense
okay now here is the thing though as
i've just pointed out
whichever way you go you have to resolve
some forces yeah you've got to be able
to say
this thing's off at a funny angle
whether it's your weight force or your
tension or your normal
it's off at a funny angle i've got to
work out which part of it's this way
and which part of it's this way do you
remember that whichever way you go you
rather do it once or do it twice okay
now i guess my question to you is is
there a better way to do this
if only right there was some kind of
technique we could deal with
that allowed us with vectors to be able
to say there's just
the part of this vector that i'm
interested in is the one for example
that's going off in in this direction
right i just want to know
which part of this vector or how much of
that vector
is going in that direction and then
conversely i'd also like to know which
part of that say tension vector
is going in this direction right
now sort of on this diagram if you're
looking in the x y plane it's almost
like like a helpful metaphor for this
would be
it's like this tension vector up here
it's kind of like
casting a shadow down on this horizontal
plane
if only i had some kind of easy to
access
technique that would allow me to work
out the lengths and directions
of such vectors except
wait a second we do know exactly such a
thing
so long as you know how to work out a
dot product it's pretty straightforward
actually
to work out something like this in a
particular direction
what's it called this is a projection
right all you're doing when you're doing
this projection whichever direction you
want
is you're working out how much of
whichever vector you're interested in
is going in the direction of some other
vector that you're interested in in this
case it'd be you know horizontal or
vertical in this case it would be
parallel to the inclined plane or
perpendicular to the incline plane
you can put it any way you like now the
reason why we didn't have to address it
here is because you might be able to see
on this diagram right
we gave you nice neat numbers so you
could do all that right angled triangle
trigonometry you got nice exact values
everything was sweet
guess what the real world resists such
simplification
right in the real world things fly off
everywhere
they don't even just fly off everywhere
in two dimensions
they fly off everywhere in three
so that's why today what i'd like you to
make a heading of is
here's a big star for you projection
for resolution right what we're doing is
resolving vectors right resolution is
the um
it's the noun for it so we're going to
use projections
for resolution
uh it's worth pointing out by the way
you will not find this heading
anywhere in the textbook you will find a
different heading which i find
remarkably unhelpful
and maybe you'll be able to work out as
we go through this which heading is
referred to i just think
that's not actually the point of it okay
draw with me a new diagram it's going to
look
quite different but it's going to have
some common features to what we've just
done here
okay i'm going to have um this is sort
of like an incline plane so it's like a
vector going off in any random direction
okay and what i want to work out is
a projection in a second to enable me to
resolve the
forces of this thing right so i think
what i call this thing i'm going to have
a
starting position a this is going to be
p i've got another vector
i think i'm going to put it i'm going to
put a short
b and that'll do for now okay
so if you have some inclined plane along
a b and then i've got some vector like
this maybe it's a
normal force or a tension force or a
weight force could be any of these
right how do i work out the part of this
that is going along parallel to the
plane this is the easy part
right i would have to say i've got a
vector here
ap this is what i'm projecting on to
so i'll give you a bit of a clue it's
going to start like this
right but then i need a base and then i
need a thing that's
casting the shadow as it were which one
is which
you've got labels here
say it again loud assessment
okay so at least we know it's a p and a
b but which one
goes down the bottom which one goes up
the top
okay i think i heard say it again
very good so i'm going to project a p
right this is the thing which is the
vector i'm interested in
and then i'm comparing it to this is
kind of like my base it's off at a funny
angle but things often are off on funny
angles right so that's
i'm deliberately drawing it like this so
ap is the thing that's being projected
onto a b like so is that okay
what would that look like if you've got
another color here it will be handy
right what would it look like it's going
to be casting a shadow from here
onto this a b here you can see what
that's why i've extended it out right
it's actually going to give us this
whole length kind of here
do you agree with that that's what
you're going to get there
okay if we got the length of it that
would be the scalar projection if we got
the thing including direction that would
be the
vector projection so far so good okay
fantastic
now this is only one piece of the puzzle
or one half of the puzzle when we
resolve vectors you can't just say oh i
just want this one right
you also have to account for it's got
movement in another direction
also right so where would the other
vector be that would be the other half
of
resolving this particular vector against
this inclined plane where would it go
now i'll admit you potentially don't
have enough language or notation to be
able to describe what's going on here
so i'll give you a huge hand and say to
you if we call this
projection aq right let me let me label
it as so
a q
does this help you at all where would
you describe
the perpendicular thing the other part
of the resolution of this vector where
would it go
q p q p
does that make sense because i'm
starting from here going in that
direction so part of it
goes here and the other one goes that
way if i were to if you want to think
about this way
come back to these guys the reason you
can know or the way you can know you've
resolved it correctly is
if you were to put this vector and that
vector the resolved pieces together
then you concatenate them one after the
other you should end up
where the sum vector is which indeed it
would if you went
a q and then like you just told me q p
i've got one piece and then i have its
perpendicular piece does this make sense
okay let's go ahead and put that onto
our diagram so
q p
this would be the other piece right and
it is
really important the whole point of
doing vector resolution is to say
they're perpendicular or
orthogonal to each other right so this
is qp
okay now i hope that you can see now
spoilers right i said you wouldn't find
this heading in your book
what we really need to do is find this
length here right so
what this is often described as and this
might call back some stuff from
advanced even is actually the distance
from
this point up here p to
this line i call it like our inclined
plane or whatever direction you're
resolving your forces in right
so it's the distance between a point and
a line
that's the shortest the distance between
a point
and a line that's the shortest and just
like if you were crossing the road
the way to cross the road the fastest is
to cross
perpendicular at right angles to that
road if you were like going off at an
angle you'd take
extra distance so this qp here if i were
to slap some
absolute value signs around it like so
what the textbook describes this as is
the
perpendicular distance from a point to a
line does this make sense this is the
same thing right
but the reason why we would care about
perpendicular distance is because
it allows us to resolve forces this is
why it's actually useful to us does that
make sense
okay so here's the question for you
you know how to compute this with a dot
product i'm not actually interested in
that
presume you do this i've given you some
value for some vector ap
i've given you some vector for a b you
get some
vector out of this right how do you then
go from that
to this i'm trying to work out this guy
and this is going to be one of the
building blocks okay
saying again but louder
minus the projection this this
projection here
a b ap rather on a b
hm let's think about this for a moment
do we agree
so what's this doing here it's saying
do these two vectors one after another
yes
so i'm going to start at a and then i'm
going to go to p
and then i'm going to do there's a minus
sign there which means going the
opposite direction
yes so i can see where this vector is
it's my green one
yes so that's going to take me the other
way so it's going to
lay me over here oops wrong color
like so so i started here
went there now i'm down here
is that what i want
i'm seeing some nods but i'm also seeing
confusion
i see a bunch of people who are nodding
if you're nodding tell me why because
it looks like i i said i wanted this
thing how is this the same
coming well like they're like the same
vectors that they have the same length
because but if you look at the graph
it's like
a rectangle first of all
actors very good
we have language to this to describe
this don't we um what kevin's talking
about is
we have two vectors here that have the
same i think you said the same length
what's the other thing that a vector
needs direction right so these are
parallel because in fact it's a
parallelogram
which we stuck a right angle into hence
a rectangle like you said carbon
this is a displacement vector is it not
right these two
are equivalent displacement vectors so
sure enough
that's fine with me okay if what i
wanted was remember the distance
right the distance in fact it doesn't
even matter about your direction anymore
i could just as easily gone
the other way think about this for a
second if i wrote down
let's compare this projection of
a p onto a b
if i did where's it going this one first
this one first
and then what i did was i subtracted a
p
think about what this is doing right i'm
going
projection first right and then i'm
subtracting ap which is where's ap
it's here so i'm going to end up in the
opposite direction over here
right so you can see you're like oh it's
either going that way or this way if all
i care about is the
perpendicular distance then it's fine
those two are the same thing i care even
less about where this thing is
so long as the length is the same does
that make sense now
you will see both of these
written because when you take the
absolute value you don't care about
whether it's positive or negative does
this make sense